people go to the doctor to get routine
blood work done on an annual basis
sometimes but when should we be
considering this for our pets dr jamie
ogenstein medical director of oasis
animal hospital in henderson has the
answer in today's pet vet segment
but once you start hitting that
geriatric age once you start hitting
seven
eight years old
it's it is actually very important
because you can find things that you're
not going to find any other way but
again blood work is telling you how the
body's functioning
it's you're not going to catch cancer
that way
um in humans people always they think
blood work well that'll tell me there's
no cancer no that's not the case in
humans they have some very specific
tests that they can run you have the psa
test for men that tells you about
prostate cancer you have markers for
breast cancer those are very specific
tests that you can run we don't quite
have those same tests in veterinary
medicine and so we're not really running
those and cancer very rarely shows up on
blood work leukemia lymphoma about the
only two that you can see
other than that you're really looking at
how the body's functioning so when you
hit seven and eight where we start
seeing geriatric pets
that's when you really do want to
actually have some routine blood work
done especially when they're just
hitting that age get a nice baseline
and then as they're continuing to age
you're gonna monitor that and see is it
changing is it changing over time
do we need to go looking do we need to
do x-rays do we need to do an ultrasound
it's not uncommon we find things uh
coincidentally you know we're doing
blood work for something else and hey
look at this that wasn't really showing
up yet but it's there so it is actually
very important to be done on a regular
basis
and that age is seven to eight for dogs
and cats
we do we do actually classify seven
eight years old pretty much everybody
gets classified as geriatric
um but they have different life
expectancy a cat
is going to age much quicker than a dog
they're going to become adult and mature
much earlier but then they're going to
live a lot longer 17 16 to 18 is average
so 17 is pretty good age for a cat
so yeah still at seven or eight a little
dog same thing they're gonna age very
quickly but they're gonna live a lot
longer versus the larger the giant breed
dogs they age a little slower but they
don't live quite as long we are seeing
them live longer than they used to
really larger giant breed dogs used to
average eight to ten years we are
actually seeing uh 10 to 14
but um but they still don't quite live
as long as most little dogs